they're purposely feminizing the men  because when you feminize men you  control Society because it's the men  that go to war it's the men that protect  the women and so when you feminize men  you literally remove the soldiers the  government and those at the top can get  away with anything because it's the men  that fight the Tyranny it's not the  women and I know that people are angry  about this I made a tweet which says the  feminization of men is the greatest  crime against humanity and it got 71 000  likes why is the feminization of men the  greatest crime against humanity they  provide for the women they provide for  their children and they fight against  tyranny and so if we don't have strong  men Society just crumbles